The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
I am going to start now by
telling you a little bit more
about Lewis theory.
Last time we went through
aspects of the cube theory of
Lewis and showed how that could
account for single bonds and
double bonds,
but not triple bonds.
And that when that was
superseded by the electron pair
theory, the idea being that
these electron pairs would,
in fact, be oriented at the
vertices of a tetrahedron.
And I showed you that
tetrahedron, as described in a
cube last time,
that you could then account for
triple bonds.
And, if you looked at the
notes, you also saw that certain
aspects of the dynamic behavior
of certain bond types,
rotation around single bonds,
hindered restricted rotation
around double bonds,
and so forth.
Those were accounted for by
this electron pair theory in
which the four pairs of
electrons were oriented at these
vertices of a tetrahedron.
So, that was another quite
important triumph of that part
of Lewis's theory.
And the problem was,
although that electron pair
theory initially put forward by
Lewis was so successful at
accounting for the properties of
many different kinds of
molecules and was a good
description of their electronic
structure, there was one class
of molecules,
a very important class of
molecules, namely those known as
aromatic.
And the most important member
of the class of aromatic
compounds is,
in fact, the benzene molecule.
Benzene has the formula C six H
six.
And we can easily calculate the
number of valence electrons in
benzene if we just say 4 for
carbon times 6,
plus 1 times 6 for the number
of valance electrons from each
of the six hydrogens.
And that is 30 electrons.
So, in trying to understand how
these 30 electrons in a valence
shell of benzene hold this
molecule together,
it is known to be a planar
molecule, how do those electrons
not only hold it together,
--
-- but how do they account for
the structure of benzene,
and how do they account for its
amazing stability?
And this picture that I have
drawn here is a representation
of benzene, I will explain to
you in a moment,
but it comes from a person by
the name of Ernest C.
Crocker.
Ernest C.
Crocker was an MIT Bachelor of
Science degree holder,
who earned that degree in 1917.
He was an MIT undergraduate
like you.
And he published a paper.
Let me write down the reference
for that paper.
This is the Journal of the
American Chemical Society,
1922, Volume 44,
Page 1618.
That paper was the first paper
in which the Lewis electron pair
theory was applied to an
understanding of the electronic
structure of aromatic molecules,
in particular,
benzene.
And the amazing thing about
that paper is --
Well, there are many amazing
things, but one of the amazing
things about that paper is that
there is only one author on that
paper, Ernest C.
Crocker.
And Ernest, who was a very
bright individual,
nonetheless did not go on in
graduate school to earn a Ph.D.
in chemistry,
had many various
chemistry-related interests.
He explained the chemistry of
many different kinds of
fragrances and odors.
I think he was referred to as
"the man with the million dollar
nose."
So, this person had quite a
variety of interests.
He worked in what was then the
Applied Chemistry Laboratory at
MIT after his graduation with
his Bachelor of Science degree.
And one of the things he was
thinking about was how to use
modern electronic structure
descriptions,
such as Lewis theory,
to explain molecules like
benzene.
And so, if you go and read this
paper, you are going to find a
very lucid discussion of how the
Lewis electron pair theory could
represent benzene according to
this formula that I have drawn
here.
And in this formula,
there is considered to be an
electron pair between each
carbon and each of the hydrogen
nuclei.
There is an electron pair along
each carbon-carbon axis,
as shown here,
and here, and so on,
all the way around the ring.
And then, finally,
you have six more electrons to
come up to the number of 30,
which is the number of
electrons in benzene.
And so, the question really is
what to do with this remaining
six electrons.
And I have shown them around
the outside of the ring,
here, which is where Ernest
arranged them in his work.
And I just want to point out
that he put forward the idea
that these six electrons were
circulating around the plane of
the ring and involved a net
one-half bond between each pair
of adjacent carbon atoms in the
benzene ring.
So, in effect,
when we draw benzene this way,
with a circle in the middle,
we know that that circle
represents the circulating six
electrons in what we are going
to call the pi system.
But Ernest C.
Crocker was the man who put the
circle into the middle of
benzene.
And he was an MIT undergrad.
And this was a sole-authored
paper.
Aromaticity has a vast history
in chemistry,
and it is still a very active
and unfolding history because of
the problems,
to our understanding,
posed by electrons that seem to
be circulating around a whole
molecule rather than localized
between pairs of nuclei.
So, Ernest Crocker,
Bachelor of Science,
1917, MIT, had a huge hand in
that.
I thought you might find that
interesting.
And, having looked at benzene
rings like that,
I will now draw them perhaps
another way that is also useful,
which comes from KekulÈ.
Because I want to continue our
discussion of Lewis acid-base
theory.
And I am going to draw two
molecules here that are going to
be pretty similar.
When I write a molecule,
as I have done here on the
left, I haven't explicitly
indicated each of the hydrogens
that are present on the
periphery of this substituted
benzene ring.
But you should understand from
a formula like this that this is
the molecule boron C 18 H 15.
And over here I am drawing
explicitly, at each of these
peripheral positions on the
substituted benzene rings,
fluorine atoms in place of the
hydrogens.
So, this is a different
00:10:17,609 --> 00:00:15,000
molecule with formula B C 18 F
These are both Lewis acids.
And based on our discussion,
last time, if you were to add
ammonia to one of these
molecules, where would the lone
pair of electrons on the ammonia
bind?
The boron.
So, yes, you have here a
trigonal planer boron center.
And, if you were to add an
ammonia molecule,
the lone pair of electrons
would come in and stick to the
boron --
-- because the boron is
electron deficient.
Just like the aluminum we
discussed last time,
it has only six electrons
around it, and it wants eight.
But what if we were to add one
ammonia molecule to a flask
containing both of those Lewis
acids that would then be
competing for the ammonia
molecule?
What I am asking you to do is
something I will ask you to do
throughout this semester,
and that is to analyze a
molecule's properties based on
its structure and its
composition.
Exactly.
She said that it would
preferentially stick to the one
with the fluorines because these
very electronegative fluorines
are drawing electron density
away from the boron.
This is one of our most
electronegative elements.
So you have a whole bunch of
fluorines in that molecule.
The whole thing,
we call it perfluorinated.
It is a perfluorinated triaryl
boron reagent.
These, in fact,
are great Lewis acids,
really powerful Lewis acids.
And they are modern Lewis acids
whose implementation in chemical
processes has come about really
in the last 10,
15 years.
And, in fact we were talking a
little bit about Professor
Schrock last time.
In some of his research,
he has used that perfluorinated
Lewis acid as an activator in
catalysis to get catalytic
polymerization reactions to
work.
And that is a very popular
approach these days in Lewis
acid chemistry.
The design of new kinds of
Lewis acids with interesting
molecular architectures is
something that is very much a
current topic of interest in
research in chemistry,
because you can make lots of
chemical processes happen when
you have something that can tug
on electron pairs.
And this one tugs a lot harder
than that one because this one
has very electronegative
fluorines to pull electron
density away from that boron and
to adjust the distribution of
the electron density in the
molecule.
And we will be talking more
about electron density and
distribution in a few minutes in
connection with what I am going
to show you now.
And that is --
That has to do with this
molecule, which is the SO two
molecule.
Anyone know where SO two
comes from in nature?
Or in the environment,
I should say?
Volcanoes, absolutely.
And also coal-burning power
plants.
Coal is a very dirty fuel,
and it contains a lot of
sulfur.
And, when you burn that coal
without controlling the way you
burn it, you emit SO two
into the atmosphere.
So, that can be a big problem.
And we will try to understand
why.
One of the things that SO two
can do when it gets into
the atmosphere is it can react
with dioxygen.
And that can give you --
-- SO three.
And if SO two and SO
three are present in the
atmosphere and if there is also
water present in the atmosphere,
acid rain, that is exactly the
type of process that we will be
talking about here.
SO two and SO three
are examples of what we
call anhydrides.
Anhydride is a word that means
without water.
And so you should not be
surprised that SO two
can react with water.
And when it reacts with water,
it takes up water.
And the product of that
reaction will look like this.
I draw it like that.
Okay.
So, H two O plus SO two going
to H two SO three.
The name of this
molecule is
sulfurous acid.
And, alternatively,
when SO three reacts
with water --
I have one extra electron pair
that should not have been there.
So, both SO two and SO three,
as they react with water,
are going from a situation in
which they are electron
deficient to a situation in
which the sulfur attains an
octet.
Okay?
And you should verify that the
number of electrons that I have
drawn up here actually is
consistent with the elements
that I am using with the stated
charge that I am using.
But when SO three
reacts with H two O to
give H two SO four,
we have now got sulfuric acid.
Okay.
And, as I did over there,
I have two acids that I want
here now to compare in terms of
their relative strengths.
Here I have a Lewis acid SO
three and a Lewis acid
SO two engaging in a
hydration reaction,
which produces sulfurous acid
and sulfuric acid.
And the type of acids that
these are on the bottom is
Bronsted acids,
--
-- distinguished from Lewis
acids in that the way that they
behave as acids is through
ionization that produces a
proton.
They are also Lewis acids
because the Lewis definition of
acidity is far more general,
in saying that acids are simply
entities that can accept a pair
of electrons.
Protons can accept a pair of
electrons, so they are Lewis
acids.
But if you are talking about
Bronsted acids,
you are talking exclusively
about protons that are produced
by ionization of some kind of a
Bronsted acid.
Which one of these is the
stronger acid?
Sulfuric acid.
And why?
Yes, down here.
You got the other one right.
Exactly.
When this ionizes,
you get SO four minus.
I will draw is a slightly
different way that is quicker.
You get HSO four minus.
There is your ionization.
And the idea now is that this O
minus that you have,
the negative charge can
actually be shared among a
greater number of
electronegative oxygens here,
namely four,
as compared to here,
where we have only three
electronegative oxygens.
It is a consideration of the
very electronegative elements in
your molecule that will help you
understand the properties that
these molecules will have in
terms of acid-base chemistry.
Now, how many electrons do we
have in the valance shell of SO
three?
00:21:00,000 --> 00:00:24,000
And, that being the case,
what molecule from last time
does that remind you of?
Maybe seeing a picture of it
will help refresh your memory.
AlCl three.
Exactly.
I am going to show it to you
anyway.
And this is going to be faster
than the last time,
if I set this up right.
Just to remind you.
And if we could have the lights
down just a little bit for a
moment.
I want to refresh your memory
of the electron density
distribution here in AlCl
three.
This is an electron density
isosurface of AlCl three.
And what you are noticing is
that the electron density drops
to a low value in between the
central aluminum and the
radially disposed chlorides,
the three chlorides that
surround that central aluminum
ion.
And the coloring in this is
such that the blue regions
represent regions in space where
there is a high probability of
finding paired electrons.
So, basically you have three Cl
minus's that are packed tightly
around an Al three plus.
This is a very ionic compound.
See the empty region in space
between aluminum and chloride,
and the polarization of that
otherwise spherical cloud of
electrons around the chloride in
the direction of that positively
charged aluminum?
There is your electron density
distribution for that.
And now I want you to keep that
in mind, and we will compare the
isoelectronic SO three
molecule to it.
SO three.
Here is another case where we
have 3 times 8,
24 valance electrons in a
system.
But the character of this
molecule in terms of electron
density distribution is very
different.
While on the blackboard,
I am not able to really tell
you very much about the
difference between SO three
and AlCl three,
here I think you can
see that indeed they are quite
different.
This is an electron density
isosurface at the same contour
level as what we were looking at
for AlCl three.
Now, to explain this and to
understand just what is going on
here, you need to remember that
the electronegativity difference
between the central sulfur and
the peripheral oxygens is not
very great compared to the
electronegativity difference
between aluminum,
which is a very electropositive
and metallic element,
and chlorine,
which is a very electronegative
halogen.
And so, what that results in,
as shown here,
is a much more equal sharing of
the electrons between that
central sulfur and these
peripheral oxygens.
So, even though these things
are both Lewis acids and they
both have 24 valance electrons,
the electron density
distribution in
three-dimensional space for
these molecules and the covalent
verses ionic character of these
molecules, is really quite
different.
Our section that is going to be
devoted to bonding has not
really kicked into gear yet,
but the nice thing is that
Lewis theory applies both to
acid-base chemistry and to
bonding, so we are able to talk
a little bit about that.
In a few moments,
I will tell you a little more
about an issue that is very
important in chemistry as
regards bonding.
And it has to do with what
happens when acids,
like sulfuric acid,
ionize in water.
When Bronsted acids ionize in
water, we get this ion produced.
H three O plus,
which is the hydronium ion.
That is to say that if you
ionize in water some Bronsted
acid, the protons that are
produced through that ionization
are not floating around freely,
naturally, because they are
positively charged and they are
attracted to negatively charged
electrons.
So, they look around in
solution and find the next
source of an electron that they
can.
And you know that if we draw
out a molecule like water,
according to the Lewis dot
structure, it has two extra
pairs of electrons,
in addition to those two pairs
of electrons it is using in
making bonds to the two
hydrogens that are on the oxygen
of the water molecule.
So, H plus is not just
isolated around by itself in
solution.
It perches on an oxygen lone
pair.
So, H three O plus is
what you get when Bronsted acids
ionize in water.
And furthermore,
when you put these things in
solution you find that you
organize the water molecules
that are close to the hydronium
ion.
Let's draw here a neighboring
water molecule.
And another one.
And I think you can imagine
that throughout a solution,
we might have many of the kinds
of interactions that I have
drawn here as dotted
peach-colored lines.
Those lines represent what we
call hydrogen bonds.
And hydrogen bonds are
enormously important in
chemistry.
Later, when we talk about the
structure of proteins in DNA,
in particular,
you may be aware that the DNA
double helix is held together by
a network of hydrogen bonds
between complimentary base
pairs.
So hydrogen bonds are not only
restricted to the hydronium ion
in aqueous solution.
There are many other types of
molecules that can form what we
call hydrogen bonds.
Another really interesting
thing is that in water,
the hydronium ion can move
around really rapidly,
much more rapidly than
molecules normally diffuse
through aqueous solution.
And the reason for that is if
you look at the arrangement of
electrons and nuclei here,
all I have to do is,
without even moving the nuclei
much at all, reorganize the
hydrogen bonding network as
such.
And now you can see that
through just a slight set of
motions, our hydronium ion has
moved from the left-hand side of
this hydrogen bonded network,
where you can see that it is
indicated with the positive
charge and the three solid lines
drawn to the oxygen,
over to the right-hand side.
But it did that not by coming
off and moving over,
but rather through just
redistribution of the electron
density, so that the positively
charged part ends up down on the
other side.
And so this way of propagating
hydronium ions in aqueous
solution is one of the really
special aspects of Bronsted acid
chemistry that takes place in
water.
And I think I will also show
you what a hydrogen bond looks
like from the standpoint of
electron density.
First, I am just going to show
you the position of the nuclei
in a very simple hydrogen bonded
system.
Here what you can see,
the oxygens are drawn in red as
spheres and the hydrogens are
drawn in white as spheres.
You can see that the geometry
around the oxygen atoms is
slightly pyramidal.
And that is due,
of course, to the presence of
that extra lone pair here,
up above one oxygen and here,
up above the other oxygen.
And what we have now is a
hydrogen serving in a bridging
fashion.
And the number of electrons in
this system is exactly 2 times
8, because we have two water
molecules and we have an
H plus.
So this is a positively charged
ion in which a hydronium ion,
and you can pick either side,
actually, is interacting with
one of the lone pairs of the
other water molecule.
And you could imagine lots of
different types of water
clusters like this that are
singly positively charged.
And people have done a lot of
work to study such clusters in
solution.
What you should remember,
though, is that the size of the
spheres that I have drawn there
to represent those oxygens and
hydrogens is somewhat arbitrary.
But what is not arbitrary is
the way that the electron
density represents a molecule
like this.
So, we will show that to you
next.
Here it is.
And if we could have the lights
down just a little bit,
please, since this one is a
little harder to see.
What you should see here is
that we have the same structure
now surrounding that
representation of the water
molecule hydrogen bonded to the
hydronium ion that I drew a
moment ago.
We now have this sort of mesh,
which is exactly what we have
been looking at with these other
molecules, namely,
an electron density isosurface.
And what you can see is that
the electron density is falling
to a pretty small value in the
middle, here,
where we have the proton that
is the connecting glue binding
together these two water
molecules in this 16 valance
electron system.
And after one more
representation of that,
we will be onto our next topic.
And this one is a solid display
of the electron density
isosurface associated with this
hydrogen bonded cluster.
And it is, once again,
color mapped with this function
that tells us about the
probability of finding electrons
paired up together in space.
There is H three O plus
hydrogen bonded to H
two O.
The blue color represents those
regions in space where you are
most likely to find pairs of
electrons.
And you can see that the two OH
bonds over here are nicely
colored blue.
The lone pair of electrons up
here is nicely colored blue.
And then we have an interesting
situation where there is some
blue in between that bridging H
plus and the two lone
pairs that are pointed at it
that produces,
in fact, our hydrogen bond.
So, there is a picture of
hydrogen bonding in terms of
electron density.
And it is a type of bonding
that compliments the straight,
covalent, and ionic bonding
that I was talking about in
terms of SO three and
AlCl three.
So, we have added this third
type of hydrogen bonding to our
list of bonding interests.
And now, we will talk more
about what we can do when we
consider Bronsted acids
ionizing.
Here is a generic
representation of the formula of
a Bronsted acid,
HA.
A might be, for example,
the HSO four minus
ion that we showed over there.
When we put a Bronsted acid in
aqueous solution,
as I said before,
we can get ionization into H
plus and A minus.
But we know that it is not just
H plus.
It is actually H three O plus
**H3O^+**.
And H three O plus is
further hydrogen bonded in
networks in the water system.
But, for simplicity,
I will just write it as H plus
right here.
Recently, in your crash review
of thermodynamics,
you were talking about
equilibria and equilibrium
constants.
And we are going to make use of
some of that right here because
we are going to talk about the
acidity constant,
Ka.
And that is going to be defined
as equal to the hydrogen or
hydronium ion concentration
times the concentration of the
conjugate base,
A minus --
When a Bronsted acid ionizes it
produces what we call the
conjugate base of the acid.
Here is conjugate base --
-- divided by the concentration
of the acid.
And this is at equilibrium.
And let me just emphasize
something so that you don't
forget.
This is an important piece of
nomenclature.
These square brackets here
refer to concentration,
usually in molarity.
Okay?
So that is what we are talking
about.
And concentration is something
that can be measured.
You may be familiar,
for example,
with the pH meter invented by
Arnold O.
Beckman and its utility in
measuring the concentration of
hydrogen ions in solution.
Well, we can make use of
information like that to talk
about the properties of our
Bronsted acids.
How can we do that?
Well, let's say we are going to
take a particular acid such as
this one, which is acetic acid.
You know the smell of acetic
acid if you have ever been in an
establishment where they were
making barbecued chicken wings.
That is the smell of acetic
acid.
A beautiful smell.
Anyway, what you do here is you
are trying to figure out what is
going on.
You have some concentration of
the acid HA, which is,
we are going to talk about,
acetic acid.
And in solution there may also
be a hydrogen ion or a hydronium
ion.
And then there may also be A
minus, which in the case of
acetic acid would be acetate,
--
-- where we have two
electronegative oxygens,
among which the negative charge
can be shared and the acetate
ion, which is the conjugate base
of acidic acid.
So we make a table.
We need to have some initial
concentration.
That is to say let's consider,
for example,
tenth molar acetic acid.
We are just choosing tenth
molar as a concentration for
acetic acid solution.
What that means is you have
pure acetic acid.
And then you dissolve it in
water and bring it up to a total
volume such that the
concentration was 0.1 molar,
assuming that none of it had
been ionized yet.
And so that means we have an
initial concentration of acetic
acid of 0.1 molar.
And initially,
before the ionization,
we have zero H plus or
hydronium and zero A minus.
And then, the concentration
changes.
And it changes because the HA
ionizes to some particular
extent, depending on the KA
value for the acetic acid.
And what is going to happen is
that some of the HA ionizes.
And the amount of the HA that
is undergoing ionization is x,
so we are going to lose x.
And then, for every HA that
ionizes, we get that same amount
of H plus produced and
that same amount of A minus.
And so then,
after the system reaches
equilibrium, we will finally
have 0.1 minus x as our
concentration of HA
and x and x will be our
concentrations,
respectively,
of H plus and A minus.
And so let me put this board
all the way up.
Therefore, we can write the
following, that Ka is equal to x
squared over 0.1 over x by
substituting into the expression
for the acidity constant.
Ka is our acidity constant.
And we can go to a table and
look up the acidity constant for
acetic acid because it is a
known quantity.
And it turns out that that is
1.8x10^-5.
And now that we have this
equation for the acidity
constant and we know what the
acidity constant is,
we can solve this for x.
Of course, this is a cubic
equation.
We are going to get two roots.
You will see that you get a
positive root and a negative
root.
The negative root is
meaningless because
concentration cannot be
negative, so you pick the
positive root.
And when you have done that,
you can then go ahead and
answer questions,
like, what is the pH of the
solution?
And what is the percent
ionization?
And we can talk about that.
So next time,
at the beginning of class,
we will do that calculation.
We will find what the pH of a
tenth molar solution of acetic
acid would be.
We will also go on and talk
about pH and the pKa scale,
and also a general equation for
discussing titrations and
buffers.